ici en france sous le signe du variant
omicron c'est la revue de presse avec
vous elle a une phrase bonjour allen
jean petit et donc à la une de la presse
française le retour à l'école et au
travail en france sacrément compliqué de
nouvelles mesures pour limiter les
contaminations et éviter une paralysie
économique d'après le parisien
aujourd'hui en france les tests vont
rythmer désormais le quotidien des
élèves les salariés vont renouer avec le
télétravail et les règles d'isolement ce
contre alléger ils n'ont rentré succo
vide donc et surtout la santé titre
libération ou le dessin de coco on le
voit montre emmanuel macron sous les
feux du variant omicron à trois mois de
la présidentielle l'exécutif veut éviter
la paralysie mais cette stratégie
risque-t-elle de provoqué un engorgement
des hôpitaux s'inquiète le journal le
figaro redoute lui que l'épidémie
conjuguée à la manie bien française
consistant à glisser sous le tapis les
questions qui fâchent conjuguent leurs
efforts pour étouffer dans l'oeuf le
débat démocratique je cite dans cette
année de présidentielle une catastrophe
selon le journal qui prévient que rien
ne serait pire qu'un simulacre de
campagne qui laisserait aux français le
goût amer d'une élection confisqué 2022
année présidentielle en france année
sportive chargée aussi avec les jeux
olympiques d'hiver en chine et la coupe
du monde de foot au qatar deux grands
événements sportifs suivie par des
milliards de téléspectateurs dans deux
pays visés on le sait par des aides pour
des atteintes avérés aux droits humains
le temps annonce une année sportive sous
surveillance en rappelant les
accusations de nombreuses ong sur les
abus perpétrés au nom du sport si le
principe du boycott comme outil de
protestation semble progresser comme en
témoigne le boycott diplomatique des jo
de pékin a annoncé par les états unis et
leurs alliés le journal note que ce
principe soit toujours à la volonté de
préserver les intérêts économiques y
compris en suisse dont l'équipe
nationale la nati
a peu de chances de boycotter la
prochaine coupe du monde de foot dans la
mesure où son principal partenaire et le
crédit suisse dont le premier
actionnaire est le fonds souverain du
qatar la question des droits humains qui
se posent également régulièrement au
maroc dont les autorités sont là accusé
par une ue tout buzz connu pour ses
enquêtes sur la corruption à la
répression de se livrer au harcèlement
et à la menace aujourd'hui exilé en
france avec son mari de l'unaf hilali
qui cherchent à obtenir l'asile
politique affirme avoir été la cible
d'une campagne de diffamation et de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est que dans la galaxie des médias
proches du pouvoir chouf tv al d'art ou
encore bach la manne une croix une
campagne orchestrée selon elle par les
autorités marocaines qui ne lui
pardonnerai ni sa dénonciation de la
gouvernance du royaume sont mohamed 6 ni
ses interviews d'opposants notamment de
l'avocat et ancien ministre des droits
de l'homme à médiane dont les prises de
position crise pourrait la monarchie ou
encore de l'ancien champion du monde de
kickboxing zakaria moumni opposant
notoire à mohamed 6 d'après libération
qui cite une source bien informée dounia
fils a lié son mari auraient été les
cibles d'une campagne éprouvé au sein
des services secrets marocains dont on a
beaucoup parlé ici qui consiste à agir à
travers des médias de diffamation
spécialisé dans des campagnes de
dénigrement intense des campagnes
destinées à saper l'intégrité le crédit
et la réputation des personnes ciblées
qui sont ainsi en quelque sorte victime
d'un meurtre symbolique on ne se
quittent pas là dessus et rennes - de
washington post pauline fait état d'un
message ma foi pas banal émis en ce
début d'année par
autorités de séoul la capitale de la
corée du sud un avertissement à
l'intention des propriétaires de chats
sur les risques d' incendies provoqués
par ces bestioles selon la municipalité
sans cet incendie très exactement a été
déclenchée par des chats au cours des
trois dernières années par des chats qui
aurait réussi à allumer des cuisinières
électriques avec leurs petites pattes
woods le quotidien américain juge
nécessaire normand de rappeler qu'il
n'ya pas que des chats pyromane et qu'il
existe aussi des chats super héros ayant
sauvé la vie de leurs maîtres comme ce
chaque canadien qui avait réussi à
réveiller son propriétaire juste à temps
le mordant au bras matin de 2017 le
sauvant in extremis d'un incendie dit
qu'il n'avait pas provoqué lui-même a
pris chat alors vers sissoko hélène
c'était la revue de presse à très vite
sur cette antenne où on se retrouve dans
un gros quart d'heure pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]